bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france contexte tendu donc
pour ce g20 on vient d'évoquer à un
certain nombre de sujets de discorde
dont les tensions entre washington et
paris la rencontre était très attendue
joe biden a donc commencé sa tournée
avec un entretien avec emmanuel macron
tout à l'heure est-ce que la brouille
entre les deux dirigeants appartient
désormais au passé
la brouille appartient au passé mais
cette histoire laissera des traces bien
entendu elle laissera des traces
parce que
donne des arguments supplémentaires
notamment à la france pour la
constitution d'une autonomie stratégique
européenne et ça
paradoxalement en fait c'est un petit
peu servir la cause du président macron
puisqu'il semble mais j'ai pas vu le
texte définitif que le président bailly
dème est accepté ou un ton courage et un
peu plus où se soit montré plus
favorable à l'idée d'une défense
européenne
ce sommet du g20 est censé préparer
notamment les travaux de la coop 26 elle
s'ouvre ce week-end en l'absence du
dirigeant du principal pollueur de la
planète la chine à quoi bon selon vous
ben je crois quand même que le g20 c'est
l'instance la plus importante qui couvre
tous les aspects à la fois
géostratégique économique sanitaire et
donc si on arrive à un accord
à des orientations en matière de climat
évidemment le g20 j'aurai un rôle
d'impulsion pour le sommet du col vide
qui se passera en angleterre quelques
jours après où le 1er novembre donc je
pense que cette caution politique même
si c'est un sommet puisque normalement
le 1er novembre y aura des chefs d'état
en angleterre mais je crois que le g20
c'est quand même l'instance la plus en
dehors du conseil de sécurité qui est
strictement cantonnées aux affaires
ils ont de sécurité comme son nom
l'indiqué l'instance la plus élevée dans
l'ordre international c'est le g20 en
fête est donc une interminable pulsions
politiques du g20 pour la commune 26
sera très sympa pour la coop 26 ans on
évoque le retour des etats-unis dans la
diplomatie climatique malgré tout
l'europe on tond rester aux avant postes
de la lutte contre les rouges contre le
réchauffement climatique est ce que
c'est elle qui mène la danse aujourd'hui
je crois que l'europe joue un rôle très
important parce que bien sûr ce n'est
pas une puissance
géopolitique importante ni
géostratégique il n'y a pas de défense
européenne mais au moins un domaine dans
lequel l'europe excellent c'est le
domaine normatif et le domaine
d'impulsion pour établir à l'échelle
mondiale un certain nombre de normes de
comportement de normes sanitaires de
danse sociale et de normes climatiques
donc je pense que l'europe en effet joue
un rôle très important
alors évidemment il est évidemment
essentiel que après la période trump les
états unis ce rallye en quelque sorte à
cette ligue pour la planète mais
l'europe gardera en tout état de cause
un rôle très important
il sera aussi question ce week-end lors
du g20 de l'accès aux vaccins la
communauté internationale s'est engagée
à fournir plusieurs milliards de doses
aux pays les plus pauvres en 2021 et en
2022 concrètement on a le sentiment que
cet engagement a du mal à être tenues
pour quelles raisons
ça honnêtement je ne sais pas il faut il
faut payer
la plupart des économies en 2020 ont
connu des récessions très importante la
france - 8 %
le la russie - 4 %
l'allemagne à 5 - 6 donc
c'est une période de gel dire je ne
viens pas tendue au point de vue
budgétaire puisque nous a ouvert les
vannes de la relance économique mais on
compte les sous quand même quand il
s'agit pas de soi donc il ya cette
question financière mais je pense lui
aussi qu'il ya une question de de
capacité de traiter l'aide c'est à dire
des pays qui sont totalement démunis ce
sont des traités qui sont ce sont des
pays pardon qui sont démunis pour eux
gérer les vaccins pour fabriquer les
usines pour est donc ce n'est pas si
simple c'est pas uniquement une question
d'argent donc je pense qu'il ya une
vraie mobilisation internationale parce
que c'est l'intérêt de tout le monde et
comme l'a dit une de vos intervenants
précédemment si on ne traite pas la
question du coc vide dans les pays les
plus pauvres mais y aura de nouvelles
variantes tous les ans et ça finira par
se répercuter sur les pays riches donc
c'est l'intérêt de tout le monde de
traité par tous la question des convives
y compris dans les pays les plus pauvres
mais il faut trouver l'argent je crois
que c'est là probablement la difficulté
la plus facile à surmonter et puis
surtout il faut créer des structures à
partir de peu de chose et donc là c'est
plus compliqué
tous les pays ne sont pas capables
d'utiliser au mieux l'aide qui leur est
attribuée merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le
temps de répondre à nos questions ce
soir sur arte france jean de gliniasty
directeur de recherche à l'institut de
relations internationales
et stratégiques
on sait l'ambassadeur de france en
russie